you might have been told as a kid that
Sugar can make your teeth fall out but
for one young extra in Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory this threat became
all too real in an unexpected way in one
scene a crown of children clamor at the
counter of a sweet shop the proprietor
while singing the now famous the
Candyman tune graciously invites the
children behind the counter to select
their treats but if you watch closely he
almost knocks one little girl's teeth
out you can see from the clip that the
little girl actually gets clogged by the
fold-up counter it's pretty safe to
assume that they didn't plan for this
and then bring a six-year-old stunt girl
on set to get nailed in the face what
makes this goof so perfect though is how
the little girl doesn't seem phased at
all she still rushes past the counter to
get at the candy
to see the full video and more great
content check out our Channel And
subscribe